you know we've talked at length about
the economic sacrifices that the
continent of Africa will have to deal
with as a result of Ebola what it means
for the economy there for the people and
for investment this is now the first
time that we've had to talk about this
being a real issue potentially back here
at home we have gotten word from the CDC
that they have confirmed the first case
being diagnosed here on home soil what
might this mean for the US economy you
know again just one case so we don't
want to be overly alarmist but if this
were to be a problem breath I think the
thing to still focus on is the
consequences for Africa for which this
is an immense human tragedy and the
disruption of trade and commerce as plus
in addition to the loss of human life is
going to be a severe blow to affected
African economies um for us you know
it's very unlikely that Ebola will kill
a barge number of people in the United
States it's not an airborne disease like
the flu you have to be a doctor or a
nurse or a family member or have
extremely close contact with someone
when they're in their infectious and
hemorrhagic stage to catch it it's not
going to be something like the nineteen
nineteen nineteen twenty Spanish flu
then killed I think two million people
in the United States and even that um
even the spanish flu had a remarkably
small impact on the US economy back then
as a whole though most people kept going
to work most goods kept being produced
it's very hard to see the effects of a
plague that would kill a million in the
economic statistics back then if you
look at the numbers that Bluebird puts
up on the screen in two or three years
ago I don't think you'll see any sign of
Ebola in the United States at all